Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It was awful. The worst moment of all was the Buckingham Palace concert, where the poor Queen pledged allegiance to the vile new culture of talentless celebrity. Any institution that has to suck up to Grace Jones and Paul McCartney to get down with the kids has plainly lost the will to live. It is a measure of how bad things have got that Her Majesty has to pretend to like the cacophonous,
感谢收听《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这太糟糕了。所有时刻中最糟糕的是白金汉宫的音乐会，可怜的女王竟然向那些毫无才华的名人所组成的卑劣新文化宣誓效忠。任何一个必须靠巴结格蕾丝·琼斯（Grace Jones）和保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）来迎合年轻人的机构，显然都已经失去了活下去的意志。女王陛下竟然不得不假装喜欢那些喧嚣的、
semi-literate, musically trite rubbish that seems to have invaded almost every space in this country. I bet she loathes it, really. Its songs are the hymns and anthems of the modern religion of the self. Self-pity, self-indulgence, drugs, loveless sex. They are the exact opposite of the Queen's pledge made on her 21st birthday in 1947 that my whole life, whether it be long or short, shall be devoted to your service uh that was a uh i think he's a journalist is he peter hitchens who is that right the he's the brother of um of christopher hitchens i think he is tom and given that you've never heard of him that was an uncanny impersonation of someone you've never heard of well i i think the uh the character emerges from from the pros from the pros so um yeah so he was right that was uh peter hitchens writing on the jubilee uh in 2012 so which one was that i can't remember at least track of my jubilees that's the diamond the diamond jubilee of elizabeth the second and um people will probably have noticed that this week uh we are celebrating the 70th jubilee
半文盲的、音乐上毫无新意的垃圾——这些垃圾似乎已经侵入了这个国家的几乎每一个角落——这恰恰说明了如今的情况已经糟糕到了什么地步。我敢打赌，她其实深恶痛绝。这些歌曲就是现代自我宗教的赞美诗和圣歌。自怜、自我放纵、毒品、没有爱情的性爱。这与女王在1947年21岁生日时许下的誓言截然相反：“我的整生，无论是长是短，都将致力于服务你们——呃，那是一个——呃，我想他是位记者吧，皮特·希滕斯（Peter Hitchens），对吗？他是——呃，克里斯托弗·希滕斯（Christopher Hitchens）的兄弟，我想是的，汤姆。鉴于你从未听说过这个人，那还真是一场惟妙惟肖的模仿，模仿一个你从未听说过的人。”好吧，我认为——呃，这个性格特征是从——从散文中——从散文中显露出来的。所以——是的，所以他是对的，那是——呃，皮特·希滕斯在2012年女王登基钻禧之际写下的文章——那么那是哪一次来着？我记不清了，我的登基庆典多得我都记混了，那是伊丽莎白二世的钻石钻禧，嗯——人们可能已经注意到了，这周——我们正在庆祝第70个钻禧庆典
the platinum jubilee platinum jubilee so the queen very much set it breaking all records and we thought it would be fun didn't we dominic actually you did it's your idea it's a brilliant idea to look at the history of jubilees yes because actually the jubilees it was a sort of mad idea on my part but then when we started looking into it i think we realized that jubilees are actually weirdly, profoundly interesting, because they're great punctuation points. They're the moments when Britain has stopped and sort of taken stock of itself. And actually, the really interesting thing that comes through from the jubilees, as we'll discover in the next sort of 45 minutes to an hour or so, it's not the spectacle of the monarch waving from
白金汉宫白金汉宫白金汉宫白金汉宫……白金庆典。白金庆典。所以女王确实创下了所有纪录，我们觉得这会很有趣，对吧，多米尼克？其实是你提出的，这是你的主意，研究钻禧的历史真是一个绝妙的主意。是的，因为实际上，钻禧——这最初可以说是我的一个疯狂想法，但当我们开始深入研究时，我想要是我们意识到钻禧其实非常、极其有趣，因为它们是伟大的标点符号。它们是英国停下脚步、盘点自身存在状态的时刻。而且，正如我们在接下来大约45分钟到一小时左右所将发现的那样，钻禧真正有趣的地方，并不是君主在
the balcony. I mean, that never changes. and it's actually not very interesting what's interesting are all the other things that are going on and the things that the country says about itself yeah where britain thinks it is and i think as we'll see with its imperial history in particular the sort of the the enmeshing of the personality of the monarch and the position of the royal family with the narrative about britain and its place in the world is really, really interesting. So it's a kind of temperature check. Yeah. On the health and fever of the nation. Yeah. You said Britain. Do other monarchs celebrate jubilees? Gosh, they must. The Dutch, the Danes, the Norwegians. But you're, well, you know about
阳台上挥手的壮观景象。我的意思是，那永远不会变。而且这其实并不是很有趣，真正有趣的是所有其他正在发生的事情，以及这个国家对自身所说的话。是的，英国认为自己处于什么位置，我想正如我们将看到的，特别是结合它的帝国历史——君主的个性和王室的地位，与关于英国及其在世界上的地位的叙事交织在—起，这真的非常、非常有趣。所以这是一种温度计。是的。用来检测这个国家的健康状况和发烧程度。是的。你刚才说的是英国。其他君主也会庆祝钻禧吗？天哪，他们肯定会的。荷兰人、丹麦人、挪威人。不过你——好吧，你对
jubilees better than I do. So I don't even know where the word comes from. So the jubilees, it's biblical and it's in Leviticus. Every seventh year. So that's the yearly equivalent of the Sabbath. The children of Israel are commanded to celebrate the sabbatical year, which basically means, you know, don't leave your fields fallow, free your slaves, all that kind of stuff. And so you have seven sabbatical years and then the year after that which is the 50th year that's the jubilee so jubilee is a 50th anniversary and don't they have catholic jubilees doesn't the pope do something yes so that's so that was introduced by um boniface the eighth who was i think we actually talked in the members um episode about
钻禧的了解比我多。所以我甚至不知道这个词是怎么来的。钻禧这个词是《圣经》里的，出自《利未记》。每七年一次。所以这相当于安息年的年际版。以色列人被命令庆祝安息年，这基本上意味着，你知道，不要让你的田地荒芜，释放你的奴隶，诸如此类的事情。所以你有七个安息年，然后之后的那个年，也就是第五0年，那就是钻禧。所以钻禧就是50周年。天主教里不也有钻禧吗？教皇不也会做什么吗？是的，所以那是——那是——由——第八世博尼法斯（Boniface VIII）引入的，我想我们其实在会员专属的
famous slaps in history do you remember that famous slaps in history. Do you remember that? Famous slaps in history. He got slapped. So he was the Pope and he got slapped by people who'd burst into his summer residence on the orders of the French King. So Boniface VIII is the Pope before the Avignon exile, and he gets into a massive bust up with the King of France. But in 1300, he instituted a jubilee. So there's some doors.
历史上的著名耳光那期节目中聊过。你还记得吗？历史上的著名耳光。你还记得吗？历史上的著名耳光。他挨了一巴掌。所以他是教皇，结果被一群奉法国国王之命闯入他避暑官邸的人给扇了耳光。所以第八世博尼法斯是阿维尼翁之囚（Avignon exile）之前的教皇，他与法国国王爆发了一场空前激烈的争吵。但在1300年，他设立了钻禧。所以有一些门——
When I was at St. Peter's last year, I noticed there was some door that only gets opened in a jubilee so and what there's some doors when i was at saint peter's last year i noticed there was some door that only gets opened in a jubilee well i don't know why i'm not sure why either the papacy has well the catholic church has jubilees i think every 25 years now yeah you can have 25 25th or 50th jubilees a famous example of monarchies celebrating anniversaries was in ancient egypt so you have the said the said festival which was celebrated every uh after 30 years and then kind of i don't know four or five years after that and so on and the whole aim was designed to restore the um the masculine potency of the pharaoh so So that's something that hasn't passed into our own modern tradition. No, although it might have done for one of the Georges.
去年我在圣彼得大教堂时，我注意到有一扇门只有在钻禧时才会打开——所以——有什么门？去年我在圣彼得大教堂时，我注意到有一扇门只有在钻禧时才会打开。好吧，我不知道为什么，我也不太确定为什么。教皇——嗯，天主教会有钻禧，我想现在大约每25年一次。是的，你可以每25年或50年举办一次钻禧。君主制庆祝周年纪念的一个著名例子是在古埃及，所以你有赛德节（Sed festival），它是在——每30年之后庆祝一次，然后在此之后的四、五年左右再次庆祝，诸如此类。而其整体目的旨在恢复法老的——男性的阳刚之气。所以——
Although typically, a friend of the show, Akhenaten, he celebrated his said after three years. So ever the rebel. And of course, we've done the Shah's great party at the beginning of the 1970s to mark the one billionth anniversary. Yeah, 2,500th anniversary yeah 2500th anniversary of cyrus of the persians so yeah and actually one of the interesting things when jubilees first came in in britain is that in the victorian period there was some resistance to them
这是没有传入我们现代传统的东西。没有，尽管它可能适用于乔治家族中的某一位。不过通常情况下，本节目的老朋友阿肯那顿（Akhenaten），他在三年后就庆祝了他的赛德节。真不愧是个叛逆者。当然，我们在20世纪70年代初做过关于伊朗国王盛大派对的节目，那是为了纪念十亿周年。不，2500周年。对，居鲁士波斯帝国的2500周年。所以——是的，事实上，当钻禧最初在英国出现时，有趣的事情之一就是维多利亚时代的人们对它们有些抵触，
because they were thought of as un-british but why did they come in so it's with george the third is the first right so the first one is george is george the third so i suppose you could argue one reason they come in is simply because george the third is setting sort of breaking records for longevity but also the timing i think is really important so it's a very odd jubilee this one um you might say overseas listeners might say it's sort of typically british in that it's kind of in the wrong year because he came to the throne in 1760, but he has his Jubilee in October 1809. So it's when he's entering into his 50th year rather than marking 50 years. And I think it's pretty clear that the reason that the Jubilee happens is really because Britain's in the Napoleonic Wars.
因为它们被认为是“非英国式的”。但它们为什么会出现呢？所以是从乔治三世开始的，对吧？所以第一个是乔治——是乔治三世。所以我想你可以认为，它们出现的一个原因很简单，就是因为乔治三世在位时间长得打破了记录。但同时，时机我认为也非常重要。所以这是一个非常奇怪的钻禧，嗯——你可能会说，海外听众可能会说这非常具有英国特色，因为它在年份上算错了，因为他是1760年登基的，但他的钻禧却在1809年10月举行。所以这是在他进入执政的第50个年头，而不是纪念满50周年。而且我认为很明显，钻禧之所以会举行，实际上是因为英国正处于拿破仑战争中，
And they want to cheer everyone up. Yeah, and the war hasn't been going terribly well. So the British have been fighting in Flanders, and that's completely bogged down. Wellington's gone off to the peninsula for the Peninsular War. But nothing has been heard from Wellington for some months, I think. And nobody really knows what's going on. Of course, because the news takes a long time to reach Britain. So nobody really knows what's going on in the Peninsular news takes a long time to reach Britain. So nobody really knows what's going on in the peninsula or everybody's tired.
他们想让所有人振作起来。是的，而且战争进展得并不是非常顺利。所以英国人一直在法兰德斯（Flanders）作战，结果完全陷入了泥潭。威灵顿（Wellington）去了伊比利亚半岛参加半岛战争。但我想威灵顿已经有几个月没有任何消息了。而且没有人真正知道发生了什么。当然，因为消息传到英国需要很长时间。所以没有人真正知道半岛上的情况——消息传到英国需要很长时间。所以没有人真正知道半岛上发生了什么——每个人都很疲惫。
You know, food prices are high. Everybody's a bit miserable. So the anniversary, so George III's 50th, is a great opportunity for people to cheer themselves up, but also to sort of feel good about being British. The other thing, of course, is that some of our, I know we have a lot of American listeners, and they may say, George III, what a terrible tyrant and stuff. But, of course, is that some of our, I know we have a lot of American listeners and they may say, George III, what a terrible tyrant and stuff. But of course, that's not at all
你知道，食品价格很高。每个人都有点苦闷。所以这个周年纪念——乔治三世的执政50周年——是一个让人们振作起来的绝佳机会，同时也让人们对身为英国人感到自豪。当然，还有一件事是，我们的许多——我知道我们有很多美国听众，他们可能会说，乔治三世，多么可怕的暴君之类的。但是，当然，这根本不是
how he was perceived in Britain. No, cooking George. Yeah, he's farmer George. He's very, very popular, by and large, with the people. He hasn't gone mad yet. He's had episodes of madness. So this is actually one of the tragic things
他在英国人心中的形象。不，是“农夫乔治”（Farmer George）。是的，他是农夫乔治。总的来说，他在人民中间非常、非常受欢迎。他还没有发疯。他经历过精神失常的发作。所以这其实是关于乔治三世最悲惨的事情之一。
about George III. So this is pretty much his last moments of sanity before. It's a nice way to go out. His daughter dies a year later, and that just drives him completely over the brink into madness. And he spends the rest of his life mad. So this is like this really is his last kind of hurrah. And basically, it's very 18th century. I mean, I know it's 1809, but it feels very 18th century.
所以这几乎是他保持理智的最后时刻，在这之后……这是一个不错的退场方式。他的女儿一年后去世了，这直接把他彻底推向了疯狂的深渊。他余生都在疯狂中度过。所以这真的就像是他的最后一次狂欢。而且基本上，这非常具有18世纪的风格——我的意思是，我知道那是1809年，但它感觉非常像18世纪。
So they have ox roasts and kind of towns and villages across plumb duff plumb duff lots of beer lots of sermons everybody sings god save the king um there are some sort of nice elements so he i mean george is quite absent because his health is so poor i mean he's he's old. He's old. He's also mentally very frail. And there's a big fete at Windsor that he goes to with his family and there are fireworks. Is that the one where there's the figure of Britannia being pulled to and fro in a chariot drawn by seahorses and illumined by fireworks?
所以他们举行烤全牛活动，全英国的城镇和村庄都举行——“普伦德夫”（plumb duff）布丁——“普伦德夫”布丁，大量的啤酒，大量的布道，每个人都高唱《天佑吾王》——有一些非常美好的元素，比如他——我的意思是乔治其实缺席了，因为他的健康状况太糟了——我的意思是，他老了。他老了。而且他在精神上也非常虚弱。温莎城堡有一个盛大的游园会，他和家人一起去了，还有烟花。是那个有不列颠尼亚（Britannia）形象被海马拉着的战车拉来拉去、并在烟花照耀下的那个吗？
Yeah. Yeah, that's right. A more striking spectacle was never witnessed. Yes. Which I find hard to believe. Well, you do get people writing accounts of this. So they clearly know it's a kind of red letter day. So there's an account of the celebration of the Jubilee,
对。是的，没错。从未见过如此惊人的奇观。是的。我觉得这很难相信。好吧，你确实能看到人们写下关于这方面的记录。所以他们显然知道这是一个值得纪念的日子。因此，有一份关于钻禧庆祝活动的记录，
collected and published by a lady, the wife of a naval officer. And that's one of these sources that we get all this from, because obviously there aren't that many sources for this compared with subsequent Jubilees. But what we do know is military deserters prisoners of war are pardoned but not if they're french and so and this is being held on the anniversary of the battle of agincourt right exactly yeah so it's a battle so it's a kind of anti-french theme to the whole thing there absolutely is um but some of the things that we now associate with Jubilees, so for example, I mean, I've still got somewhere
由一位女士收集并出版，她是一位海军军官的妻子。这就是我们获得所有这些资料的来源之一，因为与后来的钻禧相比，这次的资料显然没有那么多。但我们所知道的是，逃兵和战俘都被特赦了——但法国人除外。而且这次活动是在阿金库尔战役（Battle of Agincourt）纪念日举行的，对吧？完全正确，是的。所以这是一场战斗——整个事件有一种反法的基调，确实如此。嗯——但是我们现在与钻禧联系起来的一些事情，比如说，我的某个地方还保留着
my silver Jubilee mug from 1977. The sort of, the creation of kind of China plates and mugs and things like that. I mean, that obviously, this is a time when people do love to have China mugs and plates. And it's an absolute boom time, isn't it, for the potteries? Exactly, exactly. And that's, I mean what the reason we do it
我1977年的银禧（silver Jubilee）马克杯。那种——制作中国瓷盘、马克杯之类东西的工艺。我的意思是，很显然，这是一个人们非常喜欢瓷制马克杯和盘子的时代。对于制陶业来说，这绝对是一个繁荣时期，对吧？完全正确，完全正确。而这就是——我的意思是，我们现在之所以这样做，
now is partly a sort of legacy from all this so it's a day it's a it's a it's a sort of a it's a nice sort of jamboree but it's nothing massively more than that you know people don't use that first jubilee as an opportunity for tremendous introspection i mean it's sort of a part i say it would really be forgotten actually it's a kind of not being subsequent jubilees it's a kind of merry england it is merry england it's very merry merry england and then going mad um a few months later poor old you know what george the third it's very sad i was reading andrew roberts's biography that came out last year um and he's basically spent the last 10 years of his life weeping uncontrollably and endlessly tying up handkerchiefs and unbuttoning unbuttoning waistcoats i think that they banned um productions of king lear didn't they did they
部分原因是继承了这一切的遗产。所以这是一个日子——这是一个——这是一个——某种程度上是一个不错的狂欢节，但也没有超出这个范畴太多。你知道，人们并没有把第一次钻禧当作进行深刻内省的机会。我的意思是，它有点像一个派对，正如我所说，它其实真的会被遗忘。它不像后来的钻禧那样，它是一种“快乐的英格兰”（Merry England）。它确实是“快乐的英格兰”，非常快乐的“快乐的英格兰”，然后在几个月后发疯——可怜的老乔治三世，真是太悲伤了。我读了安德鲁·罗伯茨（Andrew Roberts）去年出版的传记——他基本上说乔治三世生命的最后10年都在无法控制地哭泣，没完没了地系手帕、解开马甲纽扣。我想他们甚至禁演了——《李尔王》的演出，不是吗？
i think they maybe that's an urban myth so um in his biography roberts basically blasts holes in the thesis that george had porphyria he says that's rubbish he he thinks he had um manic depression and and that the treatment just kind of made it no treatment was so harsh that just made it a million times worse and the treatment you know compounded the existing problem and that that's you know it wasn't it wasn't some genetic you know it wasn't some inherited kind of physical um uh complaint as has often been suspected anyway that's a subject for another day. So that's the first Jubilee, that's 1809. And then there's a big break.
我觉得他们——也许那只是个都市传说。所以——在他的传记中，罗伯茨基本上彻底粉碎了“乔治患有卟啉症”这一论点。他说那是无稽之谈。他认为乔治患有——躁郁症，而且当时的治疗手段只会让病情雪上加霜。治疗手段是如此严苛，以至于让病情恶化了千万倍。治疗手段（你知道的）加剧了本已存在的问题。而且——那并不是——那并不是某种遗传性的——某种遗传性的身体——呃，疾病，正如人们经常猜想的那样。不管怎样，那是改天再聊的话题。所以这就是第一次钻禧，那是1809年。然后中间有一个很大的间隔。
So an awful lot changes, obviously, in the next 80 or so years. So by the time we get to number two, which is Victoria's Golden Jubilee, 1887, I mean, Britain's in a very different position then. And this is the first time that you get i think it's still very much focused on the monarch but it's the first time when people are sort of slightly stopping to say aren't we great we're top nation all of this kind of stuff and you get an imperial element i think there had been some parties in in what was then bombay for george
因此，显而易见，在接下来的80年左右的时间里，发生了翻天覆地的变化。所以当我们来到第二次，也就是维多利亚女王的金禧（Golden Jubilee，1887年）时，我的意思是，英国当时的处境已经大不相同了。这是第一次——我认为它仍然非常关注君主本人，但这是人们第一次稍微停下来开始说：“难道我们不伟大吗？我们是头号大国”之类的话。而且你看到了帝国的元素。我想，在当时孟买的乔治三世时期，可能已经有一些庆祝派对，
the third but you get the imperial element really coming through as we some parties in in what was then bombay for george iii but you get the imperial element really coming through as we shall see in a second so 1887 is the year of a study in scarlet it's the year of h rider haggard's book she um you know what lord salisbury gave what the cabinet gave um queen victoria tom i do because you've sent it on your notes yeah okay he said he sent the queen a picture of himself yeah very uh very nice so victoria's been enthroned since 1837 and she's obviously lost prince albert she's been through a great sort of trough of unpopularity but she's come she's just come out the other side now has she so or does this help her come out i think it probably fits both i think she has come out of it but but it's it definitely helps um she has a uh she has a great banquet with foreign kings and princes
但帝国的元素真的开始显现出来了，正如我们稍后会看到的。所以1887年是《血字的研究》（A Study in Scarlet）出版的年头，是H·赖德·哈格德（H. Rider Haggard）的书《她》（She）出版的年头——你知道索尔兹伯里勋爵（Lord Salisbury）送给——维多利亚女王什么礼物吗，汤姆？我知道，因为你在笔记里发过。好吧，他说他送给女王一张他自己的照片。非常——非常nice。所以维多利亚女王自1837年以来一直登基在位，她显然失去了阿尔伯特亲王（Prince Albert），她经历了一个不受欢迎的低谷期，但她现在刚刚熬过了另一边，是吗？或者这帮她熬过来了？我想这两者兼而有之。我认为她确实已经走出了低谷，但——但这绝对有帮助。
so there were no foreign kings and princes for george iii's jubilee well they wouldn't be able to travel would they no exactly but now there's all kinds of there's the king of denmark and there's willy of greece and there's all these kind of and presumably one of the reasons that it's not just that transport's improved and that Britain isn't at war with the continent, but also that basically they're all related to Queen Victoria. Exactly. It's a family gathering. She's the matriarch
她举办了一场有外国国王和王子参加的盛大宴会——
of Europe, absolutely. On the 21st of June, which is a really big day, she has a parade through London and there are Indian troops in the the parade so there will see more indians later on um both in this jubilee and in the next jubilee but there's a big um uh sort of big service the queen of hawaii is there tom i know you're a big fan of the queen of hawaii
所以乔治三世的钻禧上没有任何外国国王和王子。嗯，他们当时无法旅行，对吧？不，完全正确。但现在有各种各样的人——有丹麦国王，有希腊的威利（Willy），还有所有这些——而且可以推测，原因之一不仅是交通改善了，英国不再与欧洲大陆交战，而且基本上他们都与维多利亚女王有亲戚关系。完全没错。这是一个家庭聚会。她是欧洲的族长。
don't we yeah would you like to tell everybody the Queen of Hawaii's name? Have you got the notes in front of you? No, I don't think so. It's Queen Liliuokalani, I think it is. Yes. Yeah, you didn't have the courage to pronounce it. It's because I'd forgotten what her name was. I'm going to be honest. Anyway, the Queen has this tremendous time with Victoria.
在6月21日这一天——这是一个非常重要的日子，她在伦敦举行了阅兵式，阅兵式上有印度部队——我们稍后会看到更多的印度人，无论是在这次钻禧还是在下次钻禧中。但有一个盛大的——呃——盛大的宗教仪式。夏威夷女王也在场，汤姆，我知道你是夏威夷女王的超级粉丝。
She writes all about it in her journals, and she says, you know, I felt truly grateful never to be forgotten day, blah my dear albert my dear albert blah blah she has a united kingdom dress doesn't she she does with shamrocks on it and roses and so obviously the irish question is very much in the air right yes and um well there are two elements for this jubilee so this is her her golden jubilee that are worth investigating. So one is Ireland and the other is India. What do you think? What would you like to do first? I think the Irish one is so extraordinary that you should tell people about that.
难道不是吗？你想把夏威夷女王的名字告诉大家吗？你的手头有笔记吗？不，我想没有。那是莉莉乌卡拉尼女王（Queen Liliuokalani），我想是的。是的。对，你没有勇气读出来。那是因为我忘了她的名字叫什么了。我老实说。无论如何，女王与维多利亚女王度过了一段美妙的时光。
So the Irish. So this is very, when I describe it, it will sound completely demented. Lord Salisbury, who had given the Queen a portrait of himself, part of him clearly envisaged that this might be the last gift she would ever get, because he was orchestrating a false flag, terrorist bombing plot against her and himself, and he aimed around the Jubilee. He told his daughter not to go. Yeah, well, I think the head of the Metropolitan Police. The head of the Metropolitan Police did. Told his children. It's extraordinary.
她在日记中详细记录了这一切，她说：“我感到真正感激，这是一个永生难忘的日子，等等，我亲爱的阿尔伯特，我亲爱的阿尔伯特，等等等等。”她穿了一件大不列颠群岛主题的裙子，对吧？她确实穿了，上面有三叶草和玫瑰。所以很显然，爱尔兰问题在当时非常引人注目，对吧？是的。而且——嗯，这次钻禧有两个值得探讨的元素——这是她的金禧。一个是爱尔兰，另一个是印度。你觉得呢？你想先聊哪个？我觉得爱尔兰那个太离奇了，你应该跟听众们讲讲。
So this is an amazing, amazing story. And it was uncovered by a guy called Christy Campbell, who used to work for the Sunday Telegraph. He uncovered this about 20 years ago. And basically what happened was this. Sort of Fenian terrorism is a big issue in the late 1880s. And sort of Irish republicanism, Irish nationalism generally is a big issue in the late 1880s and sort of Irish republicanism Irish nationalism generally is a massive issue but also um Irish American terrorism exactly that's right sort of supported from America and um Lord Saul's but also Parnell the great sort of Irish um sort of independent spokesman the great sort of firebrand, the darling of the kind of...
关于爱尔兰。所以这非常——当我描述它时，听起来会完全是疯狂的。索尔兹伯里勋爵曾送给女王一幅他自己的肖像，他内心深处显然预见到这可能是女王收到的最后一份礼物，因为他正在策划针对女王和他本人的“虚假旗帜”（false flag）恐怖炸弹阴谋，而他的目标正是钻禧期间。他甚至告诉他的女儿不要去。是的，好吧，我认为伦敦警察厅（Metropolitan Police）的负责人——伦敦警察厅的负责人确实这么做了。告诉了他的孩子们。这太不可思议了。
The Nicholas Sturgeon of... Exactly. He's more than Nicholas Sturgeon. He's the Nelson Mandela of Ireland. And Lord Salisbury wants to discredit him. And the way he does it, he thinks, well, I'll organise, you know, I'll basically organise a terrorist plot against me, the Queen, and everybody else at the Jubilee and make sure that Parnell is associated with it.
所以这是一个令人惊叹、叹为观止的故事。这是由一个叫克里斯蒂·坎贝尔（Christy Campbell）的人揭露的，他以前在《星期日电讯报》（Sunday Telegraph）工作。大约20年前他揭露了这件事。基本上事情是这样的。芬尼亚人恐怖主义（Fenian terrorism）是19世纪80年代末的一个大问题。而且——爱尔兰共和主义，爱尔兰民族主义通常是19世纪80年代末的一个大问题。而且——爱尔兰共和主义，爱尔兰民族主义通常是一个极其严重的问题，还有——爱尔兰裔美国的恐怖主义，完全正确，就是那种得到美国支持的恐怖主义。而且——索尔兹伯里勋爵——还有帕内尔（Parnell），伟大的爱尔兰独立代言人、伟大的煽动家、……
And obviously Salisbury doesn't intend for the plot to succeed. So they basically get this guy called General Francis Millan, who's a mercenary who has been born in Tyrone, and he's got lots of links with America, so he can get money and dynamite and all this sort of stuff. And from people in Chicago and Pittsburgh. Millen is actually working for British intelligence. And has been for years, hasn't he?
……的尼古拉·斯特金（Nicola Sturgeon）。完全正确。他比尼古拉·斯特金还要重要。他是爱尔兰的纳尔逊·曼德拉（Nelson Mandela）。而索尔兹伯里勋爵想要败坏他的名声。他采用的方法是，他心想，好吧，我要组织——你知道，我基本上要针对自己、女王以及钻禧上的所有人策划一场恐怖阴谋，并确保帕内尔与此牵连。
Yeah, he has. The thing that the whole story reminds me of is, is it the Valley of Fear? Sherlock Holmes. Oh, yes. The story where it's all about undercover agents and Americans coming to Britain and engaging in these kinds of plots. I wonder whether Conan Doyle had picked up something. Maybe. Because there's also the, is it the Orange Pips? That's about the Ku Klux Klan operating in Britain, isn't it? Maybe that's the one I'm thinking of. Yeah. But there's a lot of
很显然，索尔兹伯里并不打算让这个阴谋成功。所以他们基本上找了一个名叫弗朗西斯·米伦（Francis Millen）将军的人，他是一个出生在蒂龙郡（Tyrone）的雇佣兵，他在美国有很多关系，所以他可以从芝加哥和匹兹堡的人那里搞到资金、炸药和诸如此类的东西。米伦实际上是在为英国情报部门工作。而且已经工作好几年了，对吧？
this sort of stuff in the air in the 1880s and 1890s so that wouldn't surprise me anyway um basically the american fenians provide dynamite and money and stuff and there are two guys thomas callan and michael harkins and they sail to britain from new york and um now there's a bit of a shambles because they don't actually arrive. They don't arrive until the very day that the Jubilee has started. The procession is meant to be blowing up as is happening. So they're hours away. They're in Liverpool. They don't even get there until it's too late. But then they sort of just, you know, travel around Britain, making contact with other sort of little sort of units, sort of fenian units and that basically gives away the entire fenian network in britain to the gets rolled up yeah but but as you say the head of the metropolitan police's secret department
是的，他确实在工作。整个故事让我想起了一部作品，是《恐怖谷》（The Valley of Fear）吗？福尔摩斯探案集。哦，是的。那个故事讲的全是卧底特工和美国人来到英国参与这类阴谋的故事。我不知道柯南·道尔（Conan Doyle）是否从哪里听说了什么。也许吧。因为还有——是《五个橘核》（The Five Orange Pips）吗？那是关于三K党在英国活动的，对吧？也许那才是我脑子里想的。不过在19世纪80年代和90年代，有很多
who was an anchor james monroe he did tell his children not to go to that's very guy forks isn't it to the service it's very guy for yeah um and they did try to um associate it with parnell so the government did say you know parnell knew about this um this shows how terrible the whole thing is and it is a bizarre that lord salisbury knew about it sort of but of course the salisbury's have have form of this i know so exactly so that's how i was thinking with guy forks i mean it goes all the way back to yeah because we said in our guy forks podcast we talked about whether his ancestor had really been the architect of the gunpowder block yeah so maybe
这种事情在空气中弥漫，所以我一点也不觉得奇怪。不管怎样——基本上，美国芬尼亚人提供了炸药、资金之类的东西，有两个家伙叫托马斯·卡兰（Thomas Callan）和迈克尔·哈金斯（Michael Harkins），他们从纽约乘船来到英国——现在这里有点混乱，因为他们实际上并没有到达。直到钻禧开始的那一天，他们才抵达。游行队伍本该在发生时被炸毁的。所以他们还差好几个小时的路程。他们在利物浦。直到为时已晚，他们才赶到。但随后他们只是——你知道的，在英国四处旅行，与其他一些小型的——呃——小分队，也就是芬尼亚小分队取得联系，而这基本上把英国整个芬尼亚人网络的信息都泄露给了——网络被一网打尽了，是的。但是——正如你所说，伦敦警察厅秘密部门的负责人——
it's just a family tradition if any member of the salisbury family is listening maybe they can tell us if they're if they're planning anything this time um now the other thing that's really interesting about this Jubilee is the Indian element to it. Because, of course, Victoria is Empress of India, and it matters to her enormously that there's an Indian element. And she says, basically, my way of recognizing the Indian side to my life is to have some Indian servants servants along for the for the jubilee and they
——当时的主管詹姆斯·门罗（James Monro），他确实告诉他的孩子们不要去参加——这非常像盖伊·福克斯（Guy Forks）事件，对吧？——去参加宗教仪式。这非常像盖伊·福克斯事件——而且他们确实试图——将其与帕内尔联系起来。所以政府确实说：你知道，帕内尔知道这件事——这表明整个事情有多么糟糕。而且非常离奇的是，索尔兹伯里勋爵对此略知一二——但当然，索尔兹伯里家族有这方面的“前科”。我知道——完全正确。这就是为什么我想到了盖伊·福克斯，这可以追溯到——是的，因为我们在盖伊·福克斯的播客中讨论过，他的祖先是否真的是火药阴谋的策划者——所以也许
get a man who basically runs a prison um to to send to recommend two people and one of them is this man who ends up being called the munchie he's abdul kareem and he's the son of a hospital assistant um and he he's from near jansi it's the home to the Rani of Jhansi. Who is the Rani of Jhansi? The Rani of Jhansi is the queen who takes a leading role in what the British call the Indian Mutiny. Oh, very good. And Indians call the, what was it, the First War of Independence or something. Right. And she's a flashman.
这只是家族传统。如果索尔兹伯里家族的任何成员在收听节目，也许他们可以告诉我们，他们这次是不是在计划什么——现在，关于这次钻禧另一个非常有趣的事情是印度的元素。因为，当然，维多利亚是印度女皇（Empress of India），印度的元素对她来说至关重要。她基本上说，我承认我生活中的印度一面的方式，就是带几个印度仆人
Of course she is. Yeah. And you either she'd played cricket with you or she'd been to bed with flashman one or the other um so so there's a obviously a kind of queenly link there very nice so anyway the munchie comes he's abdul kareem he arrives in june of the 1887 the year of the um jubilee he first serves victoria a breakfast um two days after the jubilee and they become tremendous friends he He teaches her Urdu, he makes her curries,
来参加钻禧。他们找了一个基本上是管理监狱的人——来推荐两个人。其中一人就是后来被称为“蒙希”（the Munshi）的人，他叫阿卜杜勒·卡里姆（Abdul Karim），是一个医院助理的儿子——他来自詹西（Jhansi）附近。那是詹西王后（Rani of Jhansi）的故乡。谁是詹西王后？詹西王后是英国人所称的“印度大起义”中起领导作用的女王。哦，非常好！而印度人称之为——叫什么来着？第一次独立战争之类的话。对。她是个“弗拉什曼”（Flashman）式的人物。
all this sort of carry on. And everybody else hates him. They really resent him. They think that she was infatuated with him. And is this before or after she has her fling with Billy Colony? That, I don't know, actually. I'm thinking after. I think after.
当然是的。是的。要么她跟你打过板球，要么她和弗拉什曼睡过，二者必居其一——所以——所以这显然有一种女王般的联系，非常棒。不管怎样，“蒙希”来了，他叫阿卜杜勒·卡里姆，他在1887年6月——也就是钻禧那一年——抵达。钻禧结束后两天，他第一次为维多利亚女王端上早餐，他们成了极好的朋友。他教她乌尔都语，为她做咖喱，
Because I think the Munchie is sort of a bit of a replacement. billy colony that i don't know actually i'm thinking after i think after okay because i think the munchie is sort of a a bit of a replacement they've had there's been two films on that haven't there there's there's been the one with the munchie and the one with john brown yeah that's right um and obviously she became slightly infatuated didn't she we know from her her the way she was wrote about prince albert that she's quite a bit she's a very she's a woman of strong feelings, shall we say. And I think some of the correspondence was destroyed
所有这一套事情。而其他所有人都讨厌他。他们非常嫉妒他。他们认为维多利亚女王对她神魂颠倒。这是在她和比利·科洛尼（Billy Colony）的风流韵事之前还是之后？这个，我其实不知道。我觉得是在之后。我认为是之后。
after her death, or after his death, anyway. Yeah, on the orders of Edward VII. Exactly. Probably just because it was a bit embarrassing, rather than kind of... I'd be very surprised if it was kind of lewd correspondence or something. Right um we're going
因为我认为“蒙希”有点像是一个替代品。比利·科洛尼——这个我其实不知道，我倾向于认为是之后。我认为是之后——好吧，因为我觉得“蒙希”有点像是——一种替代品。关于这个已经拍过两部电影了，不是吗？有一部是关于“蒙希”的，还有一部是关于约翰·布朗（John Brown）的。是的，没错。而且显然她变得有点神魂颠倒了，对吧？我们从她写给阿尔伯特亲王的信件中知道，她是一个——可以说是一个感情强烈的人。而且我猜有些信件在她死后——或者在他死后——被销毁了，不管怎样。是的，奉爱德华七世（Edward VII）的命令。
very slowly tom very slowly well should we have a break now and then come maybe we should have a diamond jubilee return for the diamond which is it's the absolute i mean that's the acme it's the apogee of jubilees absolutely the top jubilee so that's something to look forward to okay so we will see you back after the break and when we come come back, we will be here with Queen Victoria's Diamond Jubilee. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
完全正确。可能只是因为这有点令人尴尬，而不是那种——如果是什么淫秽的信件之类的话，我会非常惊讶。好吧——我们进度很慢，汤姆，非常慢。我们现在是不是该休息一下，然后回来——也许我们应该回来聊聊钻石钻禧，那是绝对的——我的意思是，那是顶峰，那是钻禧的最高峰，绝对是最顶级的钻禧。所以这很值得期待。好了，我们休息之后见，等我们回来，我们将在这里与大家聊聊维多利亚女王的钻石钻禧。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦的固定去处。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com There were hussars from Canada
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。那里有来自加拿大的轻骑兵，
and carabiniers from Knatal, camel troops from Bikina and Dayak headhunters from North Borneo wearing bright red pillbox hats and commanded by Captain W. Raffles Flint. The 17 officers of the Indian Imperial Service troops were all princes and the Hong Kong Chinese police wore conical hats. There were Malays and Sinhalese and houses from the Niger and the Gold Coast, Jamaicans in white gaiters and ornately embroidered jackets, British Guyana police in caps like French gendarmes, Cypriot Zapiers whose fezzes struck so jarring a chord that some of the crowd hissed them, supposing them to be Turks, and a jangling squadron of Indian lancers led by a British officer in a white spiked helmet. London had never seen such a spectacle. One of the Maoris weighed 28 stone, one of the Dayaks had taken 13 human heads that was jan morris um writing uh the middle
来自纳塔尔（Natal）的卡宾枪骑兵，来自比基纳（Bikina）的骆驼部队，以及来自北婆罗洲的达雅克（Dayak）猎头族人——他们戴着鲜红色的药盒帽，由W·拉夫尔斯·弗林特船长（Captain W. Raffles Flint）指挥。印度帝国服务部队的17位军官全都是亲王，香港的中国警察则戴着斗笠。那里有马来人、僧伽罗人，来自尼日尔和黄金海岸的骑兵，穿着白色绑腿和华丽绣花夹克的牙买加人，戴着像法国宪兵一样帽子的英属圭亚那警察，塞浦路斯的扎皮尔人（Zapiers）——他们的土耳其毡帽（fezzes）刺耳得让部分人群发出嘘声，误以为他们是土耳其人——还有一队由一名戴着白色尖顶头盔的英国军官率领的、叮当作响的印度枪骑兵中队。伦敦从未见过这样的奇观。其中一个毛利人重达28英石，其中一个达雅克人斩获了13颗人头——那是詹·莫里斯（Jan Morris）——她在撰写《大英帝国的和平》（Pax Britannica）的中卷时，对钻禧游行队伍的描述。
volume of pax britannica describing the jubilee procession um and dominic you said before the break that this is the top jubilee and basically it's the top jubilee because it it coincides with the the apogée of British imperial self-confidence. It absolutely does. So I think it's the top jubilee, both, as you say, because Britain's at its zenith, but also because it's by far the most interesting. Because people at the time absolutely took this jubilee as, they took it as the crowning glory of the 19th century,
多米尼克，你在中场休息前说过，这是最顶级的钻禧。基本上，它是最顶级的钻禧，因为它与大英帝国自信心的顶峰不期而遇。确实如此。所以我觉得它是最顶级钻禧，正如你所说，既是因为英国正处于鼎盛时期，也是因为它远为最有趣。因为当时的人们绝对把这次钻禧视为——他们将其视为19世纪的最高荣耀，
the sort of climax, the moment that proved Britain was indisputably top nation. Actually, and when I say people, I don't just mean people in Britain thought that, people thought that overseas. Right, yes, they did, didn't they? So even the New York Times. Well, I mean, we'll get into the details of the Jubilee in a second. But as you say, the New York Times said, we are a part, it boasted, it boasted, we are a part and a great part of this greater Britain, which seems so plainly destined to dominate the planet. So that's 1897. I mean, there's a brilliant poem by a guy called Alfred Raleigh Goldsmith, writing in Philadelphia.
某种高潮时刻，一个证明英国无可争议地成为头号大国的时刻。事实上，当我提到“人们”时，我不仅指英国国内的人们这样认为，海外的人们也这样认为。没错，确实如此，不是吗？所以甚至连《纽约时报》——好吧，我的意思是，我们一会儿再深入探讨钻禧的细节。但正如你所说，《纽约时报》写道：“我们是这个宏大不列颠的一部分，”它吹嘘道，“我们是这个宏大不列颠的一部分，而且是重要的一部分，这个宏大不列颠显然注定要统治整个地球。”所以那是1897年。我的意思是，有一首绝妙的诗，作者是一个叫阿尔弗雷德·罗利·戈德史密斯（Alfred Raleigh Goldsmith）的人，他在费城写作：
Our father's land, our mother's home, by freedom glorified. Her conquering sons the wide world roam and plant her flag in pride. For England's fame, for thy loved name fame for thy love name have bled have won have died victoria victoria long live and nation's queen that's extraordinary isn't it that's extraordinary and the kaiser sends a telegram and um kruger's in the middle of the burr war releases two british prisoners to mark the occasion so it's um it it is a kind of international occasion yeah so well there's they've just had the Jameson raid in South Africa. That's the prisoners that he's releasing.
“我们父亲的土地，我们母亲的家园，被自由所荣耀。她征服天下的儿女四海为家，自豪地插上她的旗帜。为了英格兰的声誉，为了你挚爱的名字，他们流血，他们征服，他们牺牲。维多利亚，维多利亚，万岁，万岁，国家的女王。”这太不可思议了，不是吗？这太不可思议了。而且德皇发来了一笔电报，还有——克鲁格（Kruger）在布尔战争（Boer War）期间释放了两位英国战俘来庆祝这个节日——所以它——它确实是一个国际性的盛事。是的，好吧，他们刚刚在南非经历了詹姆森突袭（Jameson raid）。这就是他释放的那些战俘。
But yes, so Britain now has an empire with 450 million people in it. And it's expanded. It's 10 times the size it was when Victoria came to the throne. I mean, that's incredible, isn't it? The amount of change that has happened since she came to the throne, also obviously since that first jubilee of George III, is astonishing. So we're now in a world of electric light, of the telegraph,
但是是的，所以英国现在拥有一个拥有4.5亿人口的帝国。而且它还在不断扩张。它的面积是维多利亚女王登基时的10倍。我的意思是，这太不可思议了，不是吗？自从她登基以来所发生的巨变，当然还有自从乔治三世的第一次钻禧以来所发生的变化，都是惊人的。所以我们现在生活在一个电灯、电报、
of obviously of railways, of all kinds of sort of developments that are going to lead to the cinema and motorcars, planes, all this sort of stuff. Friend of the show, Lord Kitchener, is currently avenging the death of very much a friend of the show, General Gordon, in the Sudan at the time. The Battle of Omdurman is looming. So imperial sort of, imperial, I mean, can I say jingoism? I suppose, I don't know, the only person who's going to be cross is myself.
铁路的世界里，以及将引领电影、汽车、飞机等各种发展的世界里。本节目的老朋友基辛格勋爵（Lord Kitchener）——哦不，是基奇纳勋爵（Lord Kitchener），当时正在苏丹为另一位本节目的老朋友戈登将军（General Gordon）的死报仇。恩图曼战役（Battle of Omdurman）即将来临。所以帝国的某种——帝国的——我的意思是，我能说“沙文主义”（jingoism）吗？我想，我不知道，唯一会生气的只有我自己。
Imperial jingoism is absolutely at its height in the late 1890s. And one of the key political figures at the time, the man who makes the weather, as people said, is the colonial secretary, Joseph Chamberlain, Birmingham man. And he says, let's use the Jubilee as basically a festival of empire. And so the whole thing must be about the empire. So actually, Victoria takes a step,
帝国的沙文主义在19世纪90年代末绝对达到了顶峰。当时的政治关键人物之一——正如人们所说的那种呼风唤雨的人物——就是殖民大臣约瑟夫·张伯伦（Joseph Chamberlain），伯明翰人。他说，让我们把钻禧基本上当作一个帝国狂欢节来办。所以整个活动都必须围绕着帝国展开。所以实际上，维多利亚女王退居幕后了一步，
although she's the focus of it she takes a bit of a back seat partly because she's got um horrendous kind of arthritis and stuff so she can't really join in with all the sort of activities and you know who she has well you do know because you've got the notes so on the night of the 21st of june she has dinner with fran archduke franz ferdinand yeah amazing um yeah. The Kaiser doesn't go, I don't think. But he does, as I said, he sends a telegram. Yeah, he's probably worried about footwear. No, I think he'd definitely wear the right footwear
尽管她是活动的焦点，但她稍微退居二线，部分是因为她患有——可怕的关节炎之类的疾病，所以她无法真正参与到所有的各种活动中去。你知道她和谁在一起吗？——好吧，你当然知道，因为你有笔记。所以在6月21日当晚，她和奥地利大公弗朗茨·费迪南德（Archduke Franz Ferdinand）共进晚餐——太棒了。是的。德皇没有去，我想是的。但他确实像我说的，发来了一份电报。是的，他可能是在担心鞋子的款式。不，我想他去参加钻禧时绝对会穿对鞋子的。我觉得只有游艇活动才会让他手忙脚乱。至于阅兵式，他绝对是轻车熟路。但说到电报和帝国，维多利亚女王发了一份电报，不是吗？她去了白金汉宫的电报室。
to a Jubilee. I think it's yachting that scrambles him. I think military possessions, he's absolutely on top of. But talking of telegrams and the Imperial, Victoria sends a telegram, doesn't she? She goes to the telegram room in Buckingham Palace. And the message, from my heart, I thank my beloved people. And it goes winging away.
是的。她的信息是：“我从心底里感谢我深爱的人民。”这条信息飞奔而去。
It does. She presses a button. Cross the cables. She presses an electric button. To Canada and Australia and India and Africa. Exactly. All the reaches of the British Empire. And then they have this, as you described, this extraordinary parade.
确实如此。她按下了一个按钮。跨越海底电缆。她按下了一个电子按钮。发往加拿大、澳大利亚、印度和非洲。完全正确。发往大英帝国的每一个角落。然后他们有了这个——正如你所描述的——这场非我的意思是，来自地球各个角落的人们受到了人群的欢呼。
So, I mean, people from all corners of the earth who are sort of cheered by the crowd. The crowds have never seen anything like it. There are hundreds of thousands of people on the streets of London watching this colossal, colossal parade. Do you want the Daily Mail set of the parade, Tom? Up they came, more and more. Rubbish. No, no, no. It's up they came, more and more.
人群从未见过这样的景象。伦敦街头有成千上万的人在观看这场庞大无比的游行。你想听《每日邮报》（Daily Mail）对游行的描述吗，汤姆？他们一个接一个地走来，越来越多。胡说八道。不，不，不。那是“他们一个接一个地走来，越来越多。
New types, new realms at every couple of yards. An anthropological museum. A living gazetteer of the British Empire. The Queen obviously loves all this because she loves being Empress of India. She loves being the head of the empire. There's a court circular published that says that she addressed her troops in Hindustani, which was completely made up.
每隔几码就有新的类型，新的疆域。一个人类学博物馆。大英帝国的活辞典。”女王显然非常喜欢这一切，因为她热爱成为印度女皇。她热爱成为帝国的首脑。有一份出版的宫廷通告（court circular）说，她用印度斯坦语（Hindustani）向她的军队发表了讲话，而这完全是虚构的。
But when she was shown this, she said, you can print it anyway because I could have done so had I so wished. Could she? So she learnt Hindustani in Urdu. Maybe she'd learnt it from the munchie i don't know i think actually she couldn't have done but i think she could have done it in urdu yeah i suppose she could it depends how much she'd retained from the munchie
但当她看到这个时，她说：“你们管它怎么印呢，因为如果我愿意的话，我本来是能做到的。”她真的能吗？所以她学过印度斯坦语或乌尔都语。也许她是跟“蒙希”学的，我不知道。我想实际上她当时做不到，但我认为她本来可以用乌尔都语做到——是的，我想她可以，这取决于她从“蒙希”那里记住了多少。
yeah um anyway interesting yes so if there are any quick experts on queen victoria's facility with indian languages so um the the newspaper that i just referred to britain's favorite newspaper then as now um they had a special edition printed in gold ink for the daily special golden edition of the daily mail every edition is a golden edition tom very older um shouldn't it be printed in diamond it should have been printed do you want their editorial said how many millions of years has the sun stood in heaven but the sun never looked down until yesterday upon the embodiment of so much energy and power? Death is gross.
是啊，嗯，不管怎样，很有意思，对吧？所以，如果有谁对维多利亚女王掌握印度语言的熟练程度有何了解的话，那么，嗯，我刚才提到的那份报纸，也就是英国最受欢迎的报纸，当时是，现在也是，他们印制了一份金墨特刊，作为每日邮报的特别黄金版，每一版都是黄金版，汤姆，年纪更大的那个，嗯，难道不应该用钻石印吗？本应该用钻石印的，你想让他们社论怎么说呢，太阳在天空中挂了多少百万年，但直到昨天，太阳才俯瞰到如此巨大的能量和力量的化身？死亡真是太粗俗了。
I think Augustus would perhaps disagree. But there are two really interesting sort of side notes. orchestrated the whole thing. He's a big believer in protectionism, in imperial unity, all this stuff. And he hosts a colonial conference as soon as the Jubilee is over with the 11 prime ministers. So 11 places, Newfoundland, New South Wales, all these sort of places, sent delegations. They have this great meeting. And he really wants a permanent imperial council. He wants basically an imperial federation that will create a greater Britain, a genuine greater Britain.
我想奥古斯都也许会持不同意见。但还有两个非常有趣的侧面。策划了整件事。他是个坚定的贸易保护主义者，坚信帝国应该团结，诸如此类。而且他在禧庆一结束，就与11位首相召开了一场殖民地会议。所以有11个地方，纽芬兰、新南威尔士，所有这些地方，都派出了代表团。他们举行了这场盛大的会议。他真的很想要一个常设的帝国理事会。他基本上想要一个帝国联邦，从而创建一个更伟大的英国，一个真正更伟大的英国。
And they basically don't go for it. So that's a bit of a dog that doesn't bark. Because they want to keep their autonomy. Because they want their autonomy. And so even there, the height of Britain's power in 1897, this moment that, as you say, Jan Morris takes as the centrepiece of the entire book, Pax Britannica, the Jubilee, was the moment when Britain's power was greater than it ever would be again.
而他们基本上并不赞同。所以这有点像是一条没有吠叫的狗。因为他们想要保持自治。因为他们想要自治。所以即便在那里，在1897年英国权力的巅峰时刻，正如你所说，简·莫里斯将这个时刻作为整本书《不列颠治下的和平》的核心，也就是禧庆，正是英国权力达到空前绝后顶峰的时刻。
Even then, I think there's a sign that actually the sands of time are kind of… Well, yes. And so the most famous literary product of this Jubilee is a poem by Rudyard Kipling, who is, of course, famed as the of the of this jubilee is a poem by roger kipling who is of course famed as the laureate of empire and at the time is is seen as the kind of the voice of britain yeah absolutely he sums up the the imperial mood the imperial spirit in his his short stories in his poetry um he's probably the most famous writer in the world. Yeah, I think that's probably fair. And he gets asked by the Times to write a poem to mark the Jubilee.
即便在那个时候，我也觉得有一个迹象表明，时光的沙漏正在……好吧，是的。因此，这次禧庆最著名的文学成果是鲁德亚德·吉卜林的一首诗，他当然以帝国桂冠诗人的身份而闻名，当时被视为英国声音的代表，是的，绝对是的，他在他的短篇小说和诗歌中总结了帝国的基调和精神，嗯，他可能是世界上最著名的作家。是的，我想这大概很公平。然后他被《泰晤士报》邀请写一首诗来纪念禧庆。
And the poem that he writes isn't at all what people have been expecting because it's called Recessional. And it's basically a warning to Britain that it will all vanish. And so the famous verse in it, far called our navies melt away on dune and headland sinks the fire. Lo, all our pomp of yesterday is one with Nineveh and Tyre. Judge of the nation, spare us yet, lest we forget, lest we forget. And that was prompted, I think, by him seeing a review of the Royal Navy at Spithead. And he was blown away by it and then felt this kind of presentiment of doom, hubris and nemesis.
而他写的这首诗完全出乎人们的意料，因为它叫《退场诗》（Recessional）。这基本上是对英国的一个警告，警告这一切都将消逝。所以其中著名的诗句是，当我们的舰队在沙丘和岬角上消融，熊熊的烈火熄灭。瞧，我们昨日所有的显赫虚华，都与尼尼微和提尔同归于尽。万国的审判官，求你宽恕我们，以免我们忘却，以免我们忘却。我认为，这主要是因为他看到了在斯皮特黑德对皇家海军的检阅。他被深深地震撼了，然后产生了一种厄运降临、傲慢必遭天谴的预感。
It's one of the fascinating things about Kipling, isn't it? At the same time as he is extolling the empire and he absolutely believes in it. And he is the ultimate kind of, he's the poet laureate of empire but at this at this high point he writes this poem that is absolutely shadowed by impending doom well loss all that sort of yeah and i mean you of course he does celebrate empire but he is also he far from whitewashes it he no he's not he's you know he's very alert to the the dark side to it i mean he's he's a brilliant writer. We should definitely do an episode on him.
这是吉卜林最迷人的地方之一，不是吗？在他颂扬帝国、坚信帝国的同时，他绝对坚信这一点。他是那种终极的，他是帝国的桂冠诗人，但在达到这个最高点时，他写下了这首完全被灭顶之灾的阴影所笼罩的诗，好吧，失落，诸如此类的，是的，我的意思是，当然他确实在赞美帝国，但他远没有粉饰它，不，他不是，你知道的，他对黑暗面非常警觉，我的意思是，他是一位杰出的作家。我们绝对应该为他做一集节目。
We should. Because you know the poem that he originally started writing? The White Man's Burden. The White Man's Burden is the poem he started writing in the Jubilee year. And then he ditched it and then reworked it during the Spanish-American War when he sent it to Teddy Roosevelt. But I mean, the message of The White Man's Burden is utterly different from that of... And that's the fascinating thing about Kipling, that he clearly believes both things equally. He believes in empire, but he also knows that it's transitory and that it's flawed and all this sort of stuff. And I think that's why sometimes people sort of diss Kipling and they
我们应该的。因为你知道他最初开始写的那首诗吗？《白人的负担》。《白人的负担》是他开始在禧庆那一年写的诗。后来他放弃了，并在美西战争期间对其进行了修改，将其寄给了西奥多·罗斯福。但我的意思是，《白人的负担》所传达的信息与……截然不同。这就是吉卜林最迷人的地方，他显然对这两件事深信不疑。他信仰帝国，但也知道帝国是短暂的、有缺陷的，诸如此类。我想这就是为什么有时人们会贬低吉卜林，他们
say, oh, he's just a sort of crusty old reactionary, but obviously that's what... But this, I mean, that poem, Recessional, it's a poem that is equal to the irony of that British Imperial Apogee. Yeah. I mean, it beautifully conveys the mixture of hubris and looming nemesis that obviously at a century more distance we can absolutely see in it. I think, and the other reason it works so well is even at that moment in 1897 Britain is being overtaken
说，哦，他只是个顽固的老反动派，但显而易见的是……但是，我的意思是，那首诗，《退场诗》，是一首足以与英国帝国全盛时期的讽刺意味相媲美的诗。是的。我的意思是，它完美地传达了傲慢与迫在眉睫的报应的交织，在经历了一个世纪以上的距离后，我们显然能在其中看到这一点。我认为，它如此奏效的另一个原因是，甚至在1897年那个时刻，英国在经济上就已经被
by the United States and Germany economically. So even as people are wearing ever fancier hats and sort of cheering empire with ever more gusto, the sort of you know, it is beginning to fall behind. I mean, I wonder if there isn't a rule of imperialism,
美国和德国超越了。因此，尽管人们戴着越来越华丽的帽子，以越来越高的热情为帝国欢呼，但那种，你知道的，它确实开始落后了。我的意思是，我一直在想，是否存在这样一条帝国主义的规律，
that the more ludicrous the hats worn by imperialists or the headwear, the nearer to disaster it's coming. I'm sure that's true, because actually the people who are the imperialists in the 1890s are all about spectacle, pomp, pageantry. Swagger. I mean, the whole thing is a kind of confidence trick, isn't it? It is. Exactly.
那就是帝国主义者戴的帽子或头饰越荒谬，离灾难就越近。我确信这是真的，因为实际上1890年代的帝国主义者们关心的全都是视觉奇观、盛大场面和浮华庆典。趾高气扬。我的意思是，整件事不过是一场虚张声势的信任游戏，不是吗？确实是。完全如此。
Of course it is. Of course it is. But of course, the people who built the empire were not really into that because they were hard-nosed entrepreneurs trying to make money. And, you know, they wouldn't have had time to do parades because they were too busy. But it's all a kind of slight hint of smoke and mirrors about that. Definitely. The whole shebang.
当然是的。当然是的。但是，建立帝国的人其实并不热衷于此，因为他们是精明的、试图赚钱的企业家。而且，你知道的，他们可没时间搞游行，因为他们太忙了。但这一切都带有一种虚无缥缈、烟雾弹般的暗示。绝对是的。整场闹剧。
Which means that by the next Jubilee, that is becoming very evident, isn't it? So the next Jubilee is actually a bit of a poor relation of Jubilees. It's a friend of the show, George V, stamp collector, a creaser of his trousers at the sides rather than the fronts and the back. Knocked out in the first episode of the World Cup of...ly i thought because i really like george v he's one of my favorite i like a boring king and he's a very boring he's so boring um yeah but his boringness is interesting and really important like the queens so exactly so george v has steered britain from the first world war through the depression and it's just coming out to the depression now 1935 it's his silver jubilee so 25 years monarchy has had a really tough time
这意味着到了下一次禧庆时，这一点变得非常明显，不是吗？所以下一次禧庆实际上有点像是禧庆家族里不受重视的穷亲戚。他是节目的老朋友，乔治五世，集邮爱好者，裤子两侧有折痕而不是前后有折痕的那位。在世界杯的第一集里就被淘汰了……其实我觉得挺有意思，因为我真的很喜欢乔治五世，他是我最喜欢的国王之一，我喜欢无趣的国王，而他非常无趣，他是那么无趣，嗯，是的，但他的无趣很有趣，而且非常重要，就像女王一样，所以完全没错，乔治五世带领英国从第一次世界大战走过大萧条，现在正走出大萧条，1935年是他的银禧，也就是统治25周年，君主制经历了一段非常艰难的时期
obviously and if you think about his family that the kaiser has been booted out in germany the czar has been executed in russia but the british monarchy has succeeded by making itself quite humdrum and he's a very hum his humdrumness is what makes him popular. So I do like the embroidery kits that were given out that sum him up thus. Prince of sportsmen, brilliant shot, but happiest aboard his yacht. Where, of course, he does wear the right shoes.
很显然，如果你想想他的家族，德国的凯撒被赶下台了，俄罗斯的沙皇被处决了，但英国君主制通过让自己变得相当平淡而取得了成功，他是一个非常平淡的人，他的平淡正是他受欢迎的原因。所以我确实很喜欢发放的刺绣工具包，它们对他的总结如下：运动健将，枪法高超，但最快乐的还是在游艇上。当然，他在游艇上穿对了鞋子。
Well, he's a sickler. I mean, he wouldn't let people come to Buckingham Palace if they're in the wrong shoes. And I'm not making that up. Quite right too. You had to wear the right foot the right shoes well he's a sickler i mean he he wouldn't let people come to buckingham palace if they're in the wrong shoes and and i'm not making that up you know you're quite right too you had to wear the right stuff so there's a there's a it's not as big as a blowout as the other um jubilees there isn't really so much of an imperial dimension certainly not in terms of the parades although of course his jubilee is celebrated in in parts of the empire because it's the depression there is a little bit of a shadow. So they're in places where there's high unemployment or there's a strong sort of left-wing political presence.
嗯，他是个一丝不苟的人。我的意思是，如果人们穿错鞋子，他是不会允许他们进入白金汉宫的。我可不是瞎编的。完全正确。你必须穿对鞋子……鞋子，嗯，他是个一丝不苟的人，我的意思是，如果人们穿错鞋子，他是不会允许他们进入白金汉宫的，我可不是瞎编的，你知道的，完全正确，你必须穿对行头。所以，这并不是像其他那些禧庆那样盛大的狂欢，并没有那么强烈的帝国维度，当然在游行方面绝对没有，尽管当然他的禧庆在帝国的某些部分得到了庆祝，因为正值大萧条，所以有一点阴影。因此，在失业率很高或左翼政治势力强大的地方，
It's not as well supported as elsewhere. Are there kind of active demonstrations against it? There aren't really demonstrations, but for example, there's a place in Fife called Lumpinans, or Lumpinans, I think it's Lumpinans, where local communist councillors oppose celebrating the Jubilee and sort of make a fuss about it and say they're just a bunch of royal parasites. So there are hints of sort of criticism, which there absolutely were not in 1897. George's own speech mentions the Depression. So he says, In the midst of this day's rejoicing,
它没有其他地方那样受到支持。有没有针对它的积极示威活动？其实并没有什么示威活动，但例如，在法夫郡有一个叫伦平南斯（Lumpinans）的地方，或者叫伦平南斯，我想是伦平南斯，那里的当地共产主义议员反对庆祝禧庆，并对此大惊小怪，说他们只是一群皇室寄生虫。所以有一些批评的苗头，这在1897年是绝对不存在的。乔治自己的演讲提到了大萧条。所以他说：“在这庆典的日子里，
I grieve to think of the numbers of my people who are still without work. We owe it to them and not least to those who are suffering from any form of disablement or the sympathy and help that we can give and all this sort of stuff. So there's an acknowledgement of the kind of tough economic times. He's surprised.
我想到还有许多我的子民仍然失业，这让我感到痛心。我们亏欠他们，尤其是那些遭受某种形式残疾的人，我们需要给予他们力所能及的同情和帮助，诸如此类。”因此，这里承认了艰难的经济时期。他感到很惊讶。
He's famously very surprised when he goes. He goes on this sort of tour of London, the East End and stuff, and people are cheering and waving flags. And he says, which, again, is something that I think is very endearing. He says, I had no idea they felt like that about me. I'm beginning to think they must really like me for myself, which is quite sweet, I think, and quite self-knowing. But do you think that's true?
众所周知，当他出行时，他感到非常惊讶。他进行了诸如伦敦东区之类的巡游，人们在欢呼和挥舞旗帜。他说——这再次让我觉得非常讨人喜欢。他说：“我不知道他们对我有这种感觉。我开始觉得他们一定是真心喜欢我这个人。”这我觉得挺可爱，也很有自知之明。但你觉得这是真的吗？
I think people did like him for himself, actually. I think they liked his… Pooterish quality. Yeah, his pooterish quality, exactly. And actually, I think this is a very pooterish Jubilee, and that is the point. Because it's only… I was having a look when I was thinking about this Jubilee. It's only a few months.
我觉得人们确实是真心喜欢他本人。我觉得他们喜欢他那种……带有波特式的平庸特质。是的，他的波特式特质，完全正确。实际上，我认为这是一个非常具有波特式风格的禧庆，重点就在于此。因为这只是……当我考虑这次禧庆时，我查阅了一下资料。这只是几个月前的事。
So it's the previous September. The Nazis had held the Nuremberg Rally that Leni riefenstahl filmed for the triumph of the will and the contrast between that you know with the amazing light shows with this the choreography the cinematography and then this i mean the best thing about this jubilee is they invent an ancestor of coronation chicken and they name a chimpanzee jubilee at london zoo yes so in other words it's so small scale and mundane and kind of sweet that in a way that kind of it's a rebuke to the sort of strutting swagger of mussolini or the or the well i i wonder whether um because for the dictators and particularly for hitler the assumption is that that fascism is the face of the future.
所以那是前一年的九月。纳粹举行了纽伦堡集会，莱妮·里芬施塔尔将其拍摄为《意志的胜利》，那种对比——你知道的，伴随着惊人的灯光秀、编排、摄影，然后是这个——我的意思是，这次禧庆最棒的地方在于，他们发明了加冕鸡的祖先，并在伦敦动物园将一只黑猩猩命名为“禧庆”，是的！换句话说，它是如此小规模、世俗且有些可爱，在某种程度上，这可以说是对墨索里尼或……或者是那种趾高气扬的挑衅的有力回击。嗯，我在想，因为对于独裁者特别是希特勒而言，他们认为法西斯主义是未来的面孔。
It's powerful. It's dramatic. It's visual. And that the democracies are mired in decline and are shabby and dull. Yeah. And it's the difference between a crisp, you know, Nazi uniform and Chamberlain's wing collar, basically. Yeah. You know, it's, you know, umbrellas against whatever the Nazis have.
它充满力量，极具戏剧性，非常视觉化。而民主国家则陷入衰落，显得破败而沉闷。是的。这就是一件笔挺的纳粹制服与张伯伦的硬领衬衫之间的区别，基本上就是这样。是的，你知道的，这就是雨伞对抗纳粹所拥有的那些东西。
Well, it's... Turbo missiles or whatever. Exactly. What it is, is the difference between that footage you have of crowds in Nuremberg who are beside themselves with excitement, screaming at the top of their lungs and doing their Nazi salutes, absolutely invigorated and energised. And they're kind of, you know, Lenny Riefenstahl's kind of framing
嗯，这可以说是……涡轮导弹之类的东西。完全正确。这其中的区别，就在于你看到的那些纽伦堡人群的镜头里，他们激动得不能自已，声嘶力竭地尖叫着，行着纳粹礼，整个人充满活力和斗志。而他们被莱妮·里芬施塔尔那种镜头语言捕捉下来，
their prime specimens of humanity. And then meanwhile in london there are people with terrible teeth eating pies with under some bunting because of course the poor pie people are going to win because of this uh i mean there are there are two things that the british traditionally have liked to think about themselves which might seem contradictory and one is that uh they don't like to make a fuss and that waving flags is for you know we don't obsess about flags and that's for foreigners and the other thing is is that we do royal processions terribly well and they're obviously completely contradictory yeah but i guess that that this silver jubilee in 1935 perhaps uh you
仿佛是人类中的精粹。与此同时，在伦敦，有些人牙齿糟糕，在彩旗底下吃着馅饼——因为当然，吃馅饼的人最终会赢，因为这个……我的意思是，英国人传统上喜欢这样看待自己，这其中可能包含两点看似矛盾的看法，一是他们不喜欢小题大做，挥舞旗帜是——你知道的，我们不执着于旗帜，那是外国人的事；而另一方面，则是我们把皇家游行做得无懈可击。这两点显然是完全矛盾的，是的，但我想1935年的这个银禧或许，
know squares that particular circle perhaps yeah i Yeah, I think it does, because it's sort of flag-waving in an understated way, isn't it? Yeah, an apologetic way. Apologetic way, which is also true of the next Jubilee, the Silver Jubilee in 1977. Which I can actually remember. Yeah, it's one of the very first things I very vaguely remember. I was nine.
你知道的，恰好弥合了这种矛盾，也许吧。是的，我想确实如此，因为它是一种低调的挥舞旗帜，不是吗？是的，一种略带歉意的方。一种略带歉意的方式，这也同样适用于下一次禧庆，即1977年的银禧。这个我实际上还记得。是的，这是我非常模糊地记得的最早的事情之一。我当时九岁。
I was nine. Yeah. There's a photo on my website of myself at the silver jubilee looking patriotic yeah i'm waving a flag of course at the age of about sort of though it continues three or something yes exactly so this is one of the first jubilees where it inaugurated the tradition of everybody saying nobody will go it'll be a terrible disaster because and no one can um express no one can sum this up better than you, 1977, I mean, if 1935 was a bad year for Britain,
我当时九岁。是的。我的网站上有一张照片，是我在银禧庆典上显得很爱国时的样子，是的，我当然在挥舞旗帜，大约三岁还是什么的年纪……是的，正因如此，这是最早的禧庆之一，它开创了一个传统，那就是每个人都说“没人会去，这将是一场可怕的灾难”，因为没有人能……没有人能比你更好地总结这一点了，1977年，我的意思是，如果1935年对于英国来说是个糟糕的年份，
relative to other countries, 1977 is a terrible year. Yes, it is a bad year. So we'd just been bailed out by the International Monetary Fund the year before in 1976. In 1975, we'd set our post-war record of 26 inflation um so jim callahan is prime minister to be broken perhaps who knows well who knows exactly um
相比于其他国家，1977年则是一个糟糕透顶的年份。是的，确实是个糟糕的年份。所以就在前一年，即1976年，我们刚刚获得了国际货币基金组织的救助。在1975年，我们创下了战后26%的通货膨胀率记录，嗯，詹姆斯·卡拉汉是首相，这个记录或许会被打破，谁知道呢，好吧，谁知道呢，确实如此，嗯，
we've got a labor government uh they have a very funny discussion captured in tony ben's diaries where ben wants to give her uh he says what should we give her as a present he's got a great idea of a vase he's got a vase that's been carved by a Polish miner. And he thinks something like that carved out of coal would go down well with them. And it's got to be something that reflects the values of the labor movement. And James Callaghan, who's very patriotic and an absolutely staunch monarchist, sits through this kind of smiling through gritted teeth and then basically
我们有一个工党政府，他们在托尼·本恩的日记里有一段非常搞笑的讨论，本恩想送给她一个……他说：“我们应该送她什么礼物呢？”他有个极好的主意，想送个花瓶，他有一个由波兰矿工雕刻的花瓶。他认为诸如此类用煤炭雕刻的东西会很受欢迎。而且这必须是能够反映工党运动价值的东西。而詹姆斯·卡拉汉是一位非常爱国、绝对坚定的保皇派，他咬着牙微笑着听完这一切，然后基本上
gets his wife to go off and buy the queen a silver coffee pot for which each member of the cabinet has to pay 15 pounds as a contribution as if the queen didn't have a coffee pot already so obviously this is the jubilee most famous really for the sex pistols but i think it's probably true to say that um most people are not the Sex Pistols persuasion, although the song sells tons and tons of copies. Because when the day comes, as it always happens with jubilees, there's a great sort of outpouring of sort of patriotism and jollity and stuff. And I learned from you, from your notes, there were even special Jubilee editions of Penthouse, Mayfair and Forum. Very 70s. Very 70s. Did your researches lead you to...
让他的妻子去给女王买了一个银咖啡壶，内阁的每个成员都要为此支付15英镑作为份子钱，就好像女王本来没有咖啡壶似的……所以很显然，这次禧庆最著名的其实是性手枪乐队（Sex Pistols），但我认为这样说大概是对的：大多数人并不属于性手枪乐队的拥趸，尽管这首歌卖出了成吨的唱片。因为当那一天到来时，就像禧庆总是发生的那样，会出现一股巨大的爱国主义和欢乐情绪的喷涌。从你的笔记中我了解到，甚至还有《阁楼》（Penthouse）、《美爵士》（Mayfair）和《论坛》（Forum）的禧庆特刊。非常有70年代的风格。非常有70年代的风格。你的研究有没有让你……
No, I've never... I bet you can get them on eBay. Though I think it's a slightly weird thing trying to stop me on eBay. Again, if any listeners out there have copies of the special Jubilee editions, we'd be very interested to know. There's lots of people are wearing Union Jack pants and all this sort of stuff. And it's the golden age of the tea towel, isn't it? It is absolutely the golden age of the tea towel. So they do have Republican events.
不，我从来没有……我敢打赌你能在eBay上买到它们。尽管我觉得在eBay上搜索这个有点奇怪。再次重申，如果听众中有谁拥有这些特殊的禧庆特刊，我们会有兴趣知道的。有很多人穿着米字旗裤子之类的东西。这是茶巾的黄金时代，不是吗？这绝对是茶巾的黄金时代。所以他们确实举办了共和主义活动。
There's a rally organized by the libertarian communists at Blackheath, but only five people turned up. So that wasn't a great success. But actually, when you look at the, as I said before, at the beginning of the program, what's really interesting is what people say about Britain.
在布莱克希思曾由自由意志主义共产主义者组织了一场集会，但只有五个人露面。所以那算不上是个巨大的成功。但事实上，当你回顾——正如我之前在节目开头所说的那样——真正有趣的是人们对英国的看法。
So the Times, complete contrast with what newspapers had said in 1897, says, this is its leader. It says, the popular imagination can no longer feed on the glories and wonders of empire,
所以《泰晤士报》与其在1897年发表的言论形成鲜明对比，发表社论说：大众的想象力再也不能靠帝国的荣耀与奇迹来维系了，
nor it has to be admitted as the Britain of 1977, relieved it has to be admitted as the Britain of 1977, relieved of almost all its imperial baggage, present the sort of spectacle to light in the mind the bonfires of national rejoicing. And Time magazine had a very similar sort of piece, looking from America. The past quarter century has witnessed enfeeblement and decline, the end of an empire, the shrinking value of of the pound near stagnation of a formerly innovative economy it's this grim reality that the jubilee briefly banished but it will still be there to challenge britons when their party is over so the silver jubilee which i remember quite fondly because it's basically the first thing i can ever remember
它也不得不承认，1977年的英国，在卸下了几乎所有的帝国包袱之后，已经无法呈现出那种点燃全国欢庆篝火的壮观景象。《时代周刊》从美国的视角出发，也发表了一篇非常类似的文章。过去的四分之一世纪见证了国力的衰微与衰落、帝国的终结、英镑价值的缩水、曾经充满创新精神的经济几乎陷入停滞，正是这种残酷的现实，被禧庆短暂地驱散了，但当派对结束时，它依然会留在那里向英国人发起挑战。所以银禧庆典，我对它有着相当深厚的感情，因为这基本上是我记忆中的第一件事，
the sort of village fate and stuff um i think it's a great party but there's a real sense of it being a moment of escapism and what's it rain otherwise yeah exactly it rained it rained it's it's an otherwise fairly miserable sort of story um i suppose the uh as well as um sex pistols derrick jarman made a film called jubilee the following year oh yeah i know you had well i had uh toy I had Adamant. And the plot is that Elizabeth I is transported by John Dee into the present. And it's kind of, you know, Britain absolutely is worse with fires and drizzle. And I think somebody just murdered Elizabeth II. And the Queen kind of goes around and there are loads of punks. That's very Derek Jarman.
比如乡村集市之类的，嗯，我觉得这是一个很棒的派对，但它确实给人一种逃避现实的感觉，而且如果不下雨的话……是的，完全没错，下雨了，下雨了，这是一个相当凄凉的故事……我想，除了……嗯，除了性手枪乐队，德里克·贾曼（Derek Jarman）在第二年拍了一部名为《禧庆》的电影。哦，对，我知道你曾经有……我有亚当·安特（Adam Ant）。剧情是伊丽莎白一世被约翰·迪（John Dee）传送到了现代。这有点像，你知道的，英国绝对变得更糟了，到处都是火灾和毛毛雨。而且我想有人刚把伊丽莎白二世给谋杀了。女王到处走动，里面有很多朋克。这很德里克·贾曼。
Yeah. I mean, nothing particularly happens. But it's also very late 70s, isn't it? Yeah, it's very late 70s. That sort of bleak, drizzly, miserable kind of thing. Yeah, I mean, so Jubilee is the 1977 equivalent of Kipling's Recessional. Yeah. So there'd be an interesting essay there.
是的。我的意思是，并没有发生什么特别的事。但这也非常具有70年代末的风格，不是吗？是的，非常具有70年代末的风格。那种阴冷、下着毛毛雨、悲惨的感觉。是的，我的意思是，所以《禧庆》就是1977年版本的吉卜林的《退场诗》。是的。所以这里面可以写一篇很有意思的论文。
That's a very good essay, Tom. I think you should write it. So let's move on. The next Jubilee, we've got two more to go. 2002. You remember 2002? They all blur. They do blur, don't they? The last two definitely blur. Actually, you know, what I do, I remember about that, or maybe I'm muddling it with the funeral of the Queen Mother. But there was, again, there's this great right royal British tradition of saying it's all going to be a disaster and they'll be interested. then actually there were massive massive crowds yes well this is what happens and
这是一篇很好的论文，汤姆。我想你应该写写看。所以我们继续。下一个禧庆，我们还有两次。2002年。你还记得2002年吗？它们都混在一起了。确实都混在一起了，不是吗？最后这两次绝对混在一起了。事实上，你知道的，我记得关于那次的是什么，或者也许我把它和王太后的葬礼搞混了。但当时，英国又出现了那种伟大的王室传统，即宣称这将是一场灾难，人们不会感兴趣，但实际上却出现了规模极其庞大的巨大人群。是的，事情就是这样，
I remember going out thinking the way you know not even really being aware that there would be crowds not even thinking about it to go and get something and finding myself on you know just unable to move because they were so packed so the guardian I um the guardian had had great fun in the first half of the year saying what a a terrible disaster the Jubilee was going to be. Wave that flag and open that champagne, says his colonist, John O'Farrell, because for a decade now, nobody has cared about the monarchy. Hooray, we won't have to hold a street party and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then the Guardian published an editorial saying,
我记得当时走出去时觉得，你知道，甚至没有真正意识到会有那么多人群，根本没多想，只是出去买点东西，结果发现自己（在人群中）动弹不得，因为人实在是太挤了。所以《卫报》——我——《卫报》在今年上半年过得很开心，一直在说这次禧庆将是一场多么可怕的灾难。它的专栏作家约翰·奥法雷尔（John O'Farrell）说：“挥舞那面旗帜，打开香槟吧，因为整整十年了，没有人再关心君主制了。万岁，我们不必举办街头派对，啦啦啦啦啦。”然后《卫报》发表了一篇社论说，
kind of, ha, ha, ha, there aren't going to be any events. The list of events bears a forlorn look. So far, it lists a golden Jubilee snooker and paul's ornament in plymouth the planting of an oak in the village of oxhill warwickshire the planting of a jubilee garden at cranmore infant school in shirley birmingham the placing of small fountains all over london and precious little else and of course was there anything else well there was because there was this there were these huge concerts yeah but what's it were there any permanent memorials? I don't know.
“哈哈哈哈，根本不会有什么活动。活动清单看起来十分凄凉。到目前为止，它列出了一场黄金禧庆斯诺克比赛、普利茅斯的圣保罗装饰品、在沃里克郡奥克斯希尔村庄种植一棵橡树、在伯明翰雪莉的克兰莫尔幼儿学校种植一座禧庆花园、在伦敦各地放置小型喷泉，除此之外就少得可怜了。”当然，还有别的吗？嗯，确实有，因为有这个，有这些巨大的音乐会。但是，有没有什么永久性的纪念碑？我不知道。
Well, I mean... So the Guardian was right. No, no, because what everybody remembers that Jubilee for is Brian May. Yes, I do remember Brian May. Brian May on the... But it's not the equivalent of a great, mighty, flourishing, golden Jubilee, whatever it was, memorial. Well, you obviously stand with Peter Hitchens here, don't you? Who? with peter hitchens uh here don't you who peter hitchens who you obviously don't know who he is but uh you you he agrees with you that a rock
嗯，我的意思是……所以《卫报》是对的。不，不，因为每个人对那次禧庆的记忆都是布莱恩·梅（Brian May）。是的，我确实记得布莱恩·梅。布莱恩·梅在……但这并不等同于一座宏伟、盛大、繁荣的黄金禧庆纪念碑之类的东西。嗯，你在这里显然是站在彼得·希特斯（Peter Hitchens）这边，不是吗？谁？站在彼得·希特斯这边，不是吗？谁是彼得·希特斯？你显然不知道他是谁，但是……他同意你的看法，认为一场摇
concert is not appropriate and it's not no i'm fine i have no problem with rock concerts so here's the thing i'm just i'm just standing up for the guardian because you're sneering at the guardian for having said that there are no permanent memorials and i'm no, it didn't say there are no permanent memorials. It said there were going to be no good events. Okay. All right. Okay. That's what it said.
滚音乐会是不合适的，而且不是……不，我很好，我对摇滚音乐会没有任何意见。所以问题是，我只是——我只是在为《卫报》辩护，因为你在嘲笑《卫报》说那里没有永久性的纪念碑，而我——不，它没说没有永久性的纪念碑。它是说不会有什么好的活动。好吧。好吧。好吧。它是这么说的。
I take it. And actually what happened is first they hold a classical concert, the prom at the palace, and 2 really the first time, other than Elton John's appearance at Diana's funeral, that the House of Windsor had wholeheartedly embraced kind of British pop culture in that way. So Paul McCartney is there and Eric Clapton is there. Well, regular listeners will remember my brilliant rendition of Paul McCartney singing Her Majesty. But more people watch that, interestingly, than watch the Live Aid concert. That is such a Sandbrook fact. Yeah, I love that. That is such a Sandbrook fact.
我接受。实际上发生的是，首先他们举办了一场古典音乐会，即宫廷逍遥音乐会（Prom at the Palace），这真的是继埃尔顿·约翰在戴安娜王妃葬礼上露面之后，温莎王朝第一次以这种方式全心全意地拥抱英国流行文化。所以保罗·麦卡特尼去了，埃里克·克莱普顿也去了。嗯，经常收听的听众会记得我精彩演绎保罗·麦卡特尼演唱的《陛下》（Her Majesty）。有趣的是，观看那场演出的人比观看“现场援助”（Live Aid）音乐会的人还要多。这真是个桑德布鲁克式的冷知识。是的，我喜欢这个。这真是个桑德布鲁克式的冷知识。
So more people watch that and also far more people watch the next concert in 2012. 200 million people watch that concert around the world. I mean, that's a pretty big deal. The Queen, was present but she wore earplugs she wore earplugs yes and but the the um the best thing about that concert was um johnny rotten john lyden yeah he's great he's a reformed customer well i mean he he's he's he truly is the greatest punk because he he obviously hugely enjoys puncturing punk yeah which is the most punk thing to do yeah so um charles is a really good bloke who talks to plants there's nothing wrong with that yes he now says he really well he's then he's not advertising butter he then said when i heard william had popped the question to kate i had a nice cup of tea for them that's that's the spirit of 1977 yeah so anyway i think
所以观看那场音乐会的人更多，而且在2012年的下一场音乐会上观看的人更多。全世界有2.02亿人观看了那场音乐会。我的意思是，这可真是件大事。女王出席了，但她戴了耳塞。她戴了耳塞，是的，但是——那场音乐会最棒的部分是——约翰尼·罗顿（Johnny Rotten），约翰·莱顿（John Lydon），是的，他很棒，他是个改过自新的人。好吧，我的意思是，他——他确实是史上最伟大的朋克，因为他显然非常享受戳穿朋克的乐趣，是的，这正是最朋克的事情，对吧？所以，嗯，查尔斯是个挺不错的人，他会跟植物说话，这没什么不好的。是的，他现在说他真的很——当时他没有在做黄油广告。他后来又说，当听说威廉向凯特求婚时，他为他们泡了一杯好茶。这才是1977年的精神。是的，所以无论如何，我认为
that was a very important moment because the monarchy had been through this big dip with the in popularity with the death of diana and their their apparent sort of inability to emote in public and to sort of reconcile themselves to the, to the modern world. And basically the people who organized the Jubilee in 2002, I think the guy was called some Michael Pete who organized it incredibly clever kind of spin doctoring because they basically decided to harness the energies of pop and,
那是一个非常重要的时刻，因为随着戴安娜的去世以及他们明显无法在公众面前表露情感、无法让自己与现代世界达成和解，君主制经历了一段人气大幅下滑的时期。基本上，2002年组织禧庆的人——我想那家伙叫迈克尔·皮特（Michael Pete），他组织得非常巧妙，是一种精明的政治公关，因为他们基本上决定利用流行文化的能量，并
and make everyone love that. And energies of pop and make that. So everyone loved that. And they knew everybody would love that. And it just worked incredibly well to sort of revitalise their image. And that's what they basically did again 10 years later with the Diamond Jubilee, which is the most recent one, 2012. So that was the middle point of a trinity, wasn't it? So you had the Kate and William wedding in 2011,
让每个人都爱上这一点。流行文化的能量并促成这一点。所以每个人都喜欢那个。而且他们知道每个人都会喜欢那个。这在重振他们的形象方面起到了极其出色的作用。这基本上是他们十年后在钻石禧庆（即最近的一次，2012年）时又做了一次的事情。所以那是三位一体的中间点，不是吗？所以你在2011年举办了凯特和威廉的婚礼，
and then you have the Olympics in London. Yes, that was the summer I hit my six was that the summer so that was the fourth part of that um yeah so four amazing mighty events mighty events and i went to see because i had um a friend who had a special birth on the thames to watch this flotilla of ships go by oh yeah and it was designed to look like a canaletto wasn't it lots of lots of tudor type ship poured with rain didn't it to in there it didn't i mean it hailed and sleeted and it was icy and the poor duke of edinburgh had to stand there for kind of three hours and he got a chill on his bladder did that that's right and it was i mean i i thought it was the most admirable thing
然后你在伦敦举办了奥运会。是的，那是我迎来六十岁生日的夏天……那是那个夏天吗？所以那是那场盛事的第四部分……是的，所以有四场令人惊叹的盛事，伟大的盛事。我去看了，因为我有一个朋友在泰晤士报有一个特别的位置来观看这支船队驶过。哦，是的，它的设计看起来像一幅卡纳莱托（Canaletto）的画，不是吗？很多很多都铎王朝风格的船。结果下雨了，不是吗？在那种情况下。没下雨——我的意思是，下过冰雹和雨夹雪，天气冰冷刺骨，可怜的爱丁堡公爵不得不站在那里站了大约三个小时，他的膀胱受了风寒，是这样的，没错，而且——我的意思是——我认为这是最令人钦佩的事。
I watched as the Queen and Prince Philip went by. But do you remember what... Absolutely kind of rigid, standing to attention. The big story of that Jubilee was the BBC's coverage, which was absolutely mocked and derided because they didn't treat the river pageant with respect. Well, that was it, wasn't it? That was...
我看着女王和菲利普亲王从旁边经过。但你还记得什么……绝对是笔直僵硬地站着立正。那次禧庆最大新闻是BBC的转播，它遭到了彻底的嘲弄和奚落，因为他们没有以应有的敬意对待这场河上游船庆典。嗯，就是这样，不是吗？那就是……
They had ill-informed commentary, which called the Queen Her Royal highness instead of her majesty and everybody went absolutely ballistic did top columnists in the daily mail well right do you know what punchy pieces on this they didn't because i had to go down to that jubilee i had to i didn't have but I did, to be a pundit on the BBC's Jubilee Roundup. And for some complicated logistical reason, I got there an hour too early or something. So they said, oh, sit in here at the back of the sort of control room where the producer who had been outed in the Daily Mail and other newspapers that day and condemned as a traitor to the realm where the producer who was called ben somebody and was a very media person with kind of precisely the right kind of trendy glasses yeah was sort of sweating and shouting at his underlings and just generally an absolute wreck um and all the underlings were smirking
他们的解说很不专业，把女王叫成了“皇室殿下”而不是“陛下”，每个人都彻底疯了。《每日邮报》的顶级专栏作家——好啦，你知道吗？他们写了多么辛辣的文章啊？他们没有，因为我不得不去参加那个禧庆，我不得不——我其实不想去，但为了在BBC的禧庆总结节目中担任专家评论员，我还是去了。由于某种复杂的后勤原因，我早到了一个小时左右。所以他们说：“哦，坐在控制室后面的这个角落里吧。”那个制片人——他当天在《每日邮报》和其他报纸上被曝光并被谴责为国家叛徒的那个制片人——名叫本什么的，是个非常具有媒体风格的人，戴着那种恰到好处的时尚眼镜，嗯——当时正满头大汗地朝着手下大吼大叫，整个人简直彻底崩溃了，
because they had clearly been reading the papers with great enjoyment i see him utterly eviscerated by the tabloids so anyway that was good fun i enormously enjoyed that uh but that diamond jubilee was i mean that was basically a sequel to the golden jubilee it was more pop music more of the same which is i guess what they're doing this time isn't it there's going to be lots of concerts and i don't know is ed sheeran involved in some way isn't top tom cruise doing something tom cruise has done it it. Oh, has he? What did he do? He spoke in Slough or something. I can't remember. Not even Windsor.
而所有手下都在暗自窃笑，因为他们显然津津有味地拜读了那些报纸，看到他被小报体无完肤地痛批了一番。所以不管怎样，那挺有意思的，我非常享受那个过程……但那次钻石禧庆——我的意思是，那基本上是黄金禧庆的续集。里面有更多的流行音乐，更多雷同的东西，我想这也是他们这次要做的事情，不是吗？会有很多音乐会，我不知道埃德·希尔兰（Ed Sheeran）是不是也以某种方式参与其中？汤姆·克鲁斯是不是也在搞什么名堂？汤姆·克鲁斯确实搞了点什么。哦，是吗？他干了什么？他在斯劳（Slough）还是什么地方讲过话。我不记得了。甚至都不是在温莎。
Well, it might have been in Windsor. I mean, I don't know. He did something. He spoke. He looked, as he always does, you know, suspiciously young. That completely passed me by. Yeah. Tom, you're not following Tom Cruise's activities with the attention to detail that I would expect.
嗯，可能是在温莎吧。我的意思是，我不知道。他确实干了点什么。他讲了话。他看起来——正如他一贯的那样——你知道的，年轻得令人起疑。那完全从我脑子里溜过去了。是的。汤姆，你对汤姆·克鲁斯活动的关注度并没有达到我所期望的细节程度。
So what are you doing for the Jubilee, Tom? You know my commitment to getting this book done so that I can do more episodes of The Rest is History. So actually you're sacrificing yourself. I'm sacrificing my ability to share in the mood of national jollity for the good of this podcast. Are you a great man for street parties? I'd certainly go to one if it was being laid on, but I wouldn't organise it.
那你为禧庆准备做点什么，汤姆？你知道我一心扑在写这本书上，好让我能腾出时间录制更多《历史的沉淀》（The Rest is History）播客。所以实际上你在做出自我牺牲。为了这个播客，我牺牲了自己分享全国狂欢情绪的能力。你很热衷于街头派对吗？如果有人举办的话，我肯定会去，但我自己不会去组织。
Are you? No, I'm not actually. That won't surprise you at all. You hate Royal Flammarie, don't you? I just don't like public jollity. No. I think, oh, I don't mind a bit of... I like a bit of bunting.
你呢？不，其实我不是。这绝对不会让你感到意外。你讨厌皇家狂欢，不是吗？我只是不喜欢公众的狂欢。不。我想，哦，我不介意一点……我喜欢一点彩旗。
I don't mind a bit of bunting. We have some Union Jack bunting, actually. It won't surprise you tonight. I imagine Arthur must be very excited. They're doing a thing. I'll tell you what they're doing at his school. They're doing a day where everybody, each class has chosen a country of the Commonwealth thing i'll tell you what they're doing at his school they're doing a day where everybody each
我不介意一点彩旗。事实上，我们有一些米字旗彩旗。今晚这不会让你感到意外。我想阿瑟一定会非常兴奋。他们正在搞一个活动。我告诉你他们在他的学校里在搞什么名堂。他们正在办一个活动日，每个人——每个班级都选择了一个英联邦国家。我告诉你他们在他的学校里在搞什么名堂。他们正在办一个活动日，每个人——每个
class has chosen a country of the commonwealth and they're going to dress up as that country that's very 1935 right and they're going to go as a member and he came home and he said well we've got an absolutely excellent one and i said who are you all dressing up as he said he said mozambique right which has joined and i thought the english speak commonwealth of english-speaking nations it has joined i think hasn't it i think mozambique has joined although obviously it was part of the portuguese empire but i i foresee well i think that that needs to be sensitively handled dressing up as as mozambique yes yes because i obviously said well are they expecting you know a load of
班级都选择了一个英联邦国家，他们将打扮成那个国家的模样。这非常符合1935年的风格，对吧？他们将作为成员国出席。他回到家里说：“嗯，我们抽到一个绝对极棒的国家。”我问：“你们都打算打扮成什么？”他说：“他说我们是莫桑比克！”对吧，莫桑比克已经加入了。我想——说英语的英联邦国家联盟。它已经加入了，我想是的，虽然很显然它曾是葡萄牙帝国的一部分。不过我预料——嗯，我觉得这需要敏感处理，打扮成莫桑比克的模样，是的，是的，因为我显然问了：“那他们是期待看到一堆
justin trudeau style um costumes and clearly they're not because that would not be the thing um but i don't know because i don't want to send him i don't know what mozambique traditional dress is and i don't want to prejudge it in case we look well cancelable yeah well what do you do faced with that dilemma tom what having to go as mozambique as mozambique it's a good question i have no idea i don't really think about mozambique well if listeners have potent thoughts about maybe go uh wildlife perhaps goes a giraffe goes a giraffe do they have drafts in mozambique no the elephants they have elephants well there's an elephant you could go as an elephant. I mean, this is very 1897, isn't it, ultimately?
贾斯汀·特鲁多风格的服装吗？”显然不是，因为那可不是那么回事。但我不知道，因为我不想把他送去——我不知道莫桑比克的传统服饰是什么，我不想过早下结论，以免我们看起来——嗯，会被取消资格。好吧，面对这样的困境你会怎么办，汤姆？不得不作为莫桑比克出场？莫桑比克？这是一个好问题。我毫无头绪，我其实并不怎么想莫桑比克。嗯，如果听众对这个有什么高见的话，也许可以去扮演……野生动物？也许去扮演一只长颈鹿？去扮演一只长颈鹿？莫桑比克有长颈鹿吗？没有，大象。他们有大象，好吧，有一头大象，你可以扮成大象。我的意思是，这非常符合1897年的风格，不是吗，归根结底？
It is. It is. I mean, I think that the risk with celebrating a jubilee is that in decades to come, the photographs will come back and haunt you. It depends how your attire, though. If you're just wearing a nice sort of paper Union Jack hat. A Union Jack waistcoat. Yeah, if you're wearing a baby Union Jack hat,
确实是的。确实是的。我的意思是，我认为庆祝禧庆的风险在于，几十年后，这些照片会卷土重来，让你感到尴尬。不过这取决于你的穿着。如果你只是戴着一顶不错的纸质米字旗帽子。一件米字旗马甲。是的，如果你戴着一顶可爱的米字旗帽子，
you'll be absolutely fine. No, I think you've been embarrassed. Because as you said, you hate public displays of jollity. Yeah, but I'm not going to be doing it. I wouldn't wear a Union Jack hat. No, I'm saying you. You wouldn't want that. No, but I wouldn't go out. I mean, I'm not going to go out.
你绝对会没事的。不，我觉得你会觉得尴尬。因为正如你所说，你讨厌公众的狂欢展示。是的，但我不会去搞那些。我才不会戴米字旗帽子呢。不，我是说你。你不会想那样的。不，但我不会出门。我的意思是，我不会出门。
You're just going to kind of hunker down. Refuse having anything to do with it. Are you going to watch the concert? No, I'd watch the queen waving from the balcony and then i might well we all we all want to see if prince andrew's going to be there don't we i mean that's that's because that's the that's the massive great floater tom i will be waiting with pen poised to see what harry and megan are going to do yeah so are harry and megan going to be allowed there? And will Prince Andrew be released out of his dungeon? So Dom is saying that Harry and Andrew won't appear.
你打算闭门不出。拒绝跟它有任何瓜葛。你要看音乐会吗？不，我会看女王在阳台上挥手，然后我可能会——我们大家都想看看安德鲁王子会不会出席，对吧？我的意思是，那是——因为那是一个巨大的悬念，汤姆。我将拭目以待，看看哈里和梅根会做什么。是的，那么哈里和梅根会被允许去吗？安德鲁王子会被放出他的地牢吗？所以多姆（Dom）在说哈里和安德鲁不会露面。
No, they're not welcome. Dom, is that absolutely official? That's our producer. He's saying, I think it is official that they're not involved. Okay, well, that diminishes the excitement of it. What's your favourite Jubilee? If you could have gone to any of these Jubilees, will you do it?
不，他们不受欢迎。多姆，那是绝对官方的消息吗？那是我们的制作人。他在说，我认为这是官方消息，他们不会参与。好吧，那这确实降低了人们的兴奋度。你最喜欢哪个禧庆？如果你能去参加这些禧庆中的任何一个，你会去吗？
Oh, 1897. Oh, 1897. Yeah, 1897. I mean, the amazing spectacle and show. I like the thought of the ox roasts and the French. Le Plum Duff. Yeah, and the sort of Francophobia. Yes, and the warm beer of old England. Yeah, I think that would be it.
哦，1897年。哦，1897年。是的，1897年。我的意思是，那惊人的奇观和盛会。我喜欢烤全牛和法国人的想法。还有李子布丁（Plum Duff）。是的，还有那种仇法情绪。是的，还有老英格兰的温啤酒。是的，我想那就是它了。
But I think you could have had that in 1897 and seen loads of headhunters. You could, yeah. Yeah, and and seen loads of headhunters. You could, yeah. And you'd have read your golden ink edition of the Daily Mail. I wouldn't. I'd have read it in the Times. I'd have read Kipling. Well, you know what Lord Salisbury said about the Daily Mail in 1897? I've seen something disapproving for boo boys, isn't it?
但我认为你在1897年也能体验到那些，还能见到成群的猎头族。你可以的，是的。是的，还能见到成群的猎头族。你可以的，是的。而且你还可以阅读你的金墨版《每日邮报》。我才不呢。我会读《泰晤士报》。我会读吉卜林。好吧，你知道索尔兹伯里勋爵（Lord Salisbury）在1897年对《每日邮报》怎么看吗？我见过一些不赞成的评价，是针对起哄者的，对吧？
A newspaper written by office boys for office boys. Yeah, yeah. I think we've done the Jubilee justice, Tom. i think we have we've done multiple jubilee episodes yes i think it's been a right royal podcast uh you've done her majesty proud uh we hope you if you're celebrating that you enjoy it if your campaigning gets it we hope you don't then yeah then we wish you ill no i think i think it's an opportunity for everyone to enjoy themselves. Oh, no, Tom. This is the kind of appeasement mentality that I absolutely will not stand for.
一份由办公室男孩写给办公室男孩的报纸。对，对。我觉得我们已经对登基庆典做出了公正的评价，汤姆。我想是的，我们已经做过很多期登基庆典的节目了。是的，我认为这是一期非常正统的皇室播客。你让女王陛下感到骄傲。我们希望如果你在庆祝，你能享受它；如果你在抗议，我们希望你不会……好吧，那我们就祝你倒霉。不，我认为这是一个让每个人都玩得尽兴的机会。哦，不，汤姆。这种绥靖心态我是绝对不能容忍的。
Right. So enjoy your street parties. Enjoy your street parties. Have a lovely time. If you're not lucky enough to be British, you probably haven't been listening anyway, so. But I'm sure they'll be celebrating in Australia and Canada. Or maybe the Americans will be reading that poem.
好吧。那就去享受你们的街头派对吧。享受你们的街头派对，度过美好的一段时光。如果你没有那么幸运不是英国人，你可能本来就没在听，所以……但我确信他们在澳大利亚和加拿大也会庆祝。或者美国人会在读那首诗。
That would be good, wouldn't it? Actually, Dominic, for our American listeners, do you want to just take us out by reading that poem again? Our father's land, our mother's home, by freedom glorified. Her conquering sons the wide world roam, and plant her flag in pride. For England's fame, for thy loved name, have bled, have have died victoria victoria long live our nation's queen goodbye bye
那一定很不错，对吧？说真的，多米尼克，为了我们的美国听众，你想不想再把那首诗读一遍来作为结束？我们父亲的土地，我们母亲的家园，被自由所荣耀。她四海为家的英勇儿女，自豪地插上她的旗帜。为了英格兰的荣誉，为了你挚爱的名字，流过血，牺牲过。维多利亚，维多利亚，愿我们国家的女王万岁，再见，再见。
you Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. historypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取额外节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。historypod.com 本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。